c'est une affaire très grave une bavure
des mesures administratives seront à
prendre
ainsi s'est exprimé le garde des sceaux
alain peyrefitte en apprenant l'évasion
de jacques mesrine et de françois bès de
la prison de la santé à paris
en effet s'il ya quelque chose qu'on a
du mal à comprendre tout de même c'est
cette évasion en plein jour entre 10h et
10h30 ce matin de l'homme que l'on
considère comme un des plus dangereux
criminels auquel la police et eu à faire
ces dernières années et de deux de ses
complices le plus jeunes rives qui
n'était pas comme les deux autres
spécialistes de l'évasion a été tué sur
le fait du mur de la santé mesrine et
baisse ont pu s'enfuir en arrêtant une
voiture mais ce qu'il ya de plus
ahurissant dans cette histoire c'est que
ces trois hommes garder dans le quartier
de haute surveillance de la santé ont pu
s'échapper parce qu'il disposait d'un
véritable arsenal caché dans le plafond
du parloir l'endroit où il pouvait
s'entretenir avec leur avocat on a
ironisé en france souvenez vous au
moment de la sphère bader et de ses
complices sur les armes qu'on trouvait
chaque jour la prison de stuttgart et
bien la prison de la santé n'avait rien
à envier aujourd'hui à celle de stein
toujours est il que jacques mesrine est
en liberté oui mesrine fils d'industriel
architecte diplômé décoré en algérie
mais dont toute la carrière s'est
effectuée dans la délinquance d'abord
puis dans la violence armée
le procès de celui qu'on a appelé un peu
hâtivement peut-être l'ennemi public
numéro 1 a eu lieu l'an dernier 20 ans
de réclusion criminelle
mais il devait être jugé à nouveau
bientôt pour des crimes dont il s'était
rendu coupable au québec
il a publié un livre écrit dans sa
cellule et où il a vu où il avoue 39
meurtre et c'est ce que disent ceux qui
comptent bien en lisant ce livre et on
ne sait pas s'il est plus truand que me
tall un mythomane finalement en tout cas
il a adressé un certain nombre de
menaces de mort également depuis sa
cellule et le danger qu'il représente en
est peut-être plus dans le personnage
qu'il s'est fabriqué que dans celui
qu'il était réellement revenons d'abord
sur les circonstances de l'évasion de ce
matin avec maurice olivari pour bien
comprendre ce qui va suivre
deux mots d'abord sur le décor les trois
hommes qui s'apprête à faire la belle
sont détenus dans le kart
et de la plus haute sécurité c'est le
terme propre l'une des 4 l de ce grand
éventail où l'on répartit les
prisonniers en fonction de leur
caractère plus ou moins dangereux chaque
quartier comporte une aile de détention
où sont rassemblés les cellules de part
et d'autre un couloir lequel couloir
débouche sur des cours de promenade
chaque prisonnier de ce quartier étant
isolé même pendant la promenade à 9h50
donc ce matin deux hommes tournent en
rond chacun dans sa petite cour mesrine
et baisse 9h55 mesrine est appelée au
parloir parloir réservé aux avocats
au bout de quelques minutes mesrine
prétend vouloir montrer à son avocate
maître giletti que leur conversation est
enregistrée que des micros sont
effectivement caché dans le faux plafond
mesrine monte alors sur la table ouvre
ce qui n'était en fait qu'une cache et
en sort cinq revolver dans ce trou sont
enfouis outre les armes des bombes
lacrymogènes de protection des fusées de
détresse et une corde marine de 12 m
pendant ce temps la baisse demande à
rentrer de promenade il rejoint mesrine
et ensemble les deux hommes pénètrent
dans le prétoire
ici à droite où sont enfermés en
permanence un surveillant et deux sous
directeur
les gardiens sont aussitôt maîtrisé
dépouillés de leur uniforme et de leurs
papiers est enfermé dans une cellule
celle du troisième larron rives
il ne reste plus qu'à retourner dans
l'une des cours de promenade à franchir
un premier mur avant d'utiliser des
échelles providentiel laisser la part
des ouvriers en train de renforcer
comble d'ironie les fenêtres de la
prison entre temps l'alerté a été donnée
l'un des gardiens de la paix en faction
dans la rue aperçoit les fugitifs tirs
sur yves qu'il tue sur le coup mesrine
et baisse ont le temps d'arrêter une
voiture et de disparaître sans laisser
pour l'instant du moins de traces